BECOMEAIREY MUCH.> UT,
FOR RAO FRE, RADIO
FRAR AP ASELY G N,
OM MOBEDIERS WHO ARE ALREATHE
FRON ACARTRIDGES. REGION, LUHAN.
WEON
T MOSCOW
THREE ET
WAENRA
E THAT THE ONE
REE BULLETGES.
THAT WAS THE E
THAT THE TOWN
WE JUSARM MENTIOEFNSK.
SO WHAT DOES IOU THAT
THIS IN THATAVTS
IF YOU TAKE A LOOK A  THIS PAPE'
VERY COMMON OB
THIS GUY WASOUGHT TO SHOOTING R
RT., WE KTH A
LI THEY ARE NOT EVENTHRY REGIST.
AND THENBEING E BORDER ANDT TOI.
SOACRAINING IS
AT'S WHATHE WIVE
T.
WTHAT ON SOCIAL
MEDIA. A
NE THIS POINT?
>> WE ED REPORTS ABOUD
ER
YESTERDAY THERE WAS A STY
REGISTRATIONICHE NED ABOUT NOT Y
MINISTER OF DEFENSE.
SHE LEARNEAT
SOCIALLY AFTER THAT SHE WAS ABLE
TO CALL TH GISTRATION OFFE.
KNOWEN TO CALLER TTHEYON
S
AT ONE MOMENT  SAID THAT HE
W.BUT MOST PROBABLY HE WAS KIL.
BUT THIS IS UNIRMED.